[Musik]
noch weniger kontakt noch weniger
bewegung bund und länder beschließen
schärfere corona maßnahmen vor allem für
hot spots besonders ansteckend mit einem
harten lockdown will großbritannien die
grassierende virus mutation in den griff
bekommen und schon wieder eine
richtungswahl im us bundesstaat georgia
entscheidet sich ob die beiden wirklich
eine chance bekommt die usa neu zu
gestalten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg ein spannender
nachrichten tag guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den sport treiben oder familie
sie haben es gerade gehört die
pressekonferenz von bund und ländern zum
krone gipfel läuft noch die botschaft
ist deutlich das infektionsgeschehen in
deutschland seien nach wie vor viel zu
hoch auch die kommenden drei monate
werden erhebliche geduld und disziplin
aller erfordern deshalb folgende
beschlüsse alle bestehenden maßnahmen
werden bis zum 31 januar verlängert
gastronomie und einzelhandel bleiben
also weiter geschlossen ebenso schulen
und kitas kontakt beschränkungen werden
noch mal verschärft treffen sind nur
noch mit einer anderen person erlaubt
und die bewegungsfreiheit der
bevölkerung in hot spots wird
eingeschränkt heike slansky berichtet
neues jahr altes ritual vorfahrt vorm
kanzleramt wieder ein corona gipfel
wieder weitgehend digital die kanzlerin
mit den verantwortlichen der länder
stunden langes ringen um maßnahmen wie
man das virus in den griff kriegen kann
ergebnis der lok darum geht weiter und
zwar deutlich verschärft unser ziel
bleibt es natürlich weiter unter 50
infizierte pro 100000 einwohnern in
sieben tagen zu kommen warum damit die
nachverfolgung der infektionsketten
wieder möglich ist
das gewinnt noch einmal an bedeutung
weil wir von einer mutation des virus
kenntnis erlangt haben
aus großbritannien die sich schneller
verbreitet und damit mehr infektionen
pro kontakt verursacht das heißt also
hier müssen wir besonders vorsichtig
sein
die infektionszahlen nach wie vor viel
zu hoch bei drei viertel aller land und
stadtkreise liegt die inzidenz bei über
100 deshalb in den hotspots soll die
bewegungsfreiheit deutlich eingeschränkt
werden
dafür plädierte unter anderen thüringens
ministerpräsident ramelow und vorfeld
ich werde die zahlen auf den tisch legen
und ich werde auch heute in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz auf der
seite derjenigen argumentieren die sagen
wir werden es noch viel schlaf
und viel härter angehen müssen wenn wir
aus der infektionsgeschehen aus dem
infektionsgeschehen rauskommen wollen
kontakte sollen weiterhin aufs nötigste
reduziert werden private zusammenkünfte
alleine oder mit den
haushaltsangehörigen nur noch mit einer
haushalts fremden person
kritik kommt von der linken gebrauchen
die differenzierung bundesweite
leitplanken aber bitte auch eine
perspektive
das licht am ende des tunnels darf nicht
nur herbeigeredet werden es muss real da
sein das ziel unter 50 neuinfektionen
pro 100000 einwohner zu kommen erst dann
könne gelockert werden und darüber werde
in drei wochen wieder verhandelt ja und
jack und anna bahn ag in berlin
beobachtet die laufende pressekonferenz
hinterland warum hat es so lange
gedauert eigentlich schienen sich doch
bund und länder relativ einig über die
verschärfungen
ja das waren sie wohl auch michael
müller der vorsitzende der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat gerade
gesagt ist die verhandlungen waren
konstruktiv aber schwer weil man sich
eben darauf geeinigt hat nicht nur den
shutter und zu verlängern sondern
tatsächlich auch noch die maßnahmen zu
verschärfen und das hat eben zeit
gebraucht da hat man sich vor allem über
die einschränkung der bewegungsfreiheit
noch einmal unterhalten aber auch über
schulen und kitas die jetzt auch
weiterhin bis zum ende des monats
mindestens geschlossen bleiben sollen
und man hat eben auch noch mal über das
impfen geredet und das hat alles zeit
gekostet welche rolle spielt die
mutation des corona virus die jetzt
offenbar in großbritannien die zahlen
explodieren lässt ja doch offensichtlich
eine erhebliche wir haben es gerade eben
in der pressekonferenz von angela merkel
schon gehört dass diese mutation eben in
den überlegen den überlegungen mit dabei
gewesen ist und sie hat auch von anfang
an sorge ausgelöst das virus verbreitet
sich deutlich schneller
das ist das ergebnis dieser sitzung
davon sind also die ministerpräsidentin
und präsidenten überzeugt und genau da
möchte man ansetzen so was wie einen
abwehrwall bauen
um diese virusvariante nicht noch weiter
ausufern zu lassen
auch da kann natürlich die einschränkung
der bewegungsfreiheit helfen wir hatten
das gehört sie soll eingegrenzt werden
auf 15 kilometer rund um den hotspot
angela merkel hat leider vorhin noch
nicht gesagt ob es da um betroffene
kreise geht bei 200 lieber über 200
infektionen liegen
aber das werden wir gleich sicherlich
noch einmal erfahren das wird dann noch
einmal präzisiert werden sie hat auch
gesagt dass soll auch die bewegungen
einschränken die wir zuletzt gesehen
haben wenn es im freizeit geht zum
beispiel im wintersport gebieten wo die
leute doch ins frei gedrängt sind und
dann relativ dicht gedrängt auf einander
gestalten uns saßen also einige punkte
sind noch offen sobald wir mehr wissen
du beobachtest weiter die
pressekonferenz gehen wir noch mal nach
berlin und fragen nach dankeschön für
den moment und anna banerjee zu den
beschlüssen gibt es ein zdf spezial
direkt nach uns außerdem können sie in
unserer zdf heute app die details zu den
bund länder beratungen noch einmal punkt
für punkt nachlesen wir haben gehört in
sogenannten hot spots wollen bund und
länder den bewegungsradius der bürger
einschränken das betrifft alle kreise
und städte die eine inzidenz von
vermutlich 200 infektionen oder mehr pro
100.000 einwohner in einer woche haben
dort sollen sich bürger nur noch 15
kilometer von ihrem wohnort entfernen
dürfen zb im thüringischen eisenach und
dort ist meine kollegin melanie haack
weil er nie was genau kommt er auf die
menschen zu ja das heißt in der tat
stärkere einschränkungen für die
menschen hier in eisenach liegt die
inzidenz bei 293 die sieben tage
incidents und ich habe gerade mit den
menschen gesprochen
sie sind wirklich verhalten die einen
sagen okay es ist in ordnung das jetzt
härtere maßnahmen kommen sollen
andere kritisieren sie und sagen auch
diese häppchenweise verschärfung sei
nicht richtig und es gibt eben auch
menschen die sagen sie wollen sich ihre
freiheit nicht nehmen lassen sich frei
zu bewegen stand jetzt was wir wissen
heißt es ja dass für
diejenigen die den radius von 15
kilometern überschreiten dies nur aus
triftigen gründen möglich ist reisen
tagesausflüge und einkaufen gehört nicht
dazu
und genau darin sieht beispielsweise der
landrat des wartburgkreises ein problem
der wartburgkreis liegt hier rund um
eisenach hat eine inzidenz von 311 und
im gegensatz zur stadt hier ist das eine
strukturschwache ländliche region und da
müssen die menschen mitunter mehr als 15
kilometer unterwegs sein um zum nächsten
supermarkt zu kommen und da ist
natürlich die frage wie diese regelung
des 15 kilometer radius jetzt in der
praxis aussieht und was das für die
betroffenen menschen in den sogenannten
hot spots bedeutet in thüringen wird im
anschluss heute abend noch das kabinett
tagen und dann wird es auch hier weitere
einzelheiten zu der regelung geben
dankeschön live aus eisenach war das
melanin das trifft jeden von uns seit
neun wochen ist deutschland wieder im
shutdown wirtschaft kulturkontakte
umarmungen alles runter gefahren und
jetzt wird das ganze noch mal verschärft
und verlängert wir haben stellvertretend
drei menschen gefragt was das für sie
bedeutet
oliver deuker isabel de la vega und
stefan kech berichten
noch hat florian reetz aus braunschweig
ferien am montag beginnt für den
abiturienten wieder die schule wie genau
weiß er noch nicht wegen der
dreharbeiten trägt der 18 jährige auch
zu hause eine maske schule unter corona
schon ein dreiviertel jahr keine leichte
zeit
es ist eine zeit von der ungewissheit
und in gewisser weise auch ein
unwohlsein achterbahnfahrt unterricht
auf dem handy wie man es regelmäßig hat
es halt doch schon sehr einschränken und
macht halt überhaupt nicht spaß
der unterricht sollte in der schule
stattfinden aber wenn es nicht möglich
ist halt das super blöd wenig direkte
kontakte in der schule und auch privat
schach online mit seinem kumpel justus
statt football training mit der
mannschaft es nervt es ist natürlich was
anderes wenn man die wirklich so
tatsächlich trifft mit dem spricht die
sehen kann
abitur machen unter corona er macht sich
seine gedanken wie das laufen wird es
bleibt abwarten und tee trinken prinzip
hoffnung in diesen pracht saal wo sonst
rauschende feste gefeiert werden ärgert
sich robert mangold über die
salamitaktik der politik
wieder ist der lockdown für sein
business verlängert worden was ihnen
besonders belastet das warten immer
wieder warten wir brauchen einen plan
und wir brauchen nicht immer wieder nur
durchhalteparolen in 14 tagen in drei
wochen im frankfurter restaurant im
palmengarten wird momentan nur first
take away gekocht 140 mitarbeiter sind
in kurzarbeit
umsatzverluste je nach unternehmen
zwischen 50 und 80 prozent
ja es gab zwar die wunderbaren hilton im
november/dezember wovon noch kein euro
geflossen ist
mangold wird weiter warten müssen auf
die staatlichen zuschüsse und ein
endgültiges ende des lok downs corona
haben insgesamt demütiger gemacht silvia
köppen betreut als bereichsleiterin
pflege mehrere intensivstationen der
leipziger uniklinik die situation sei
angespannt
etliche kollegen sind selbst erkrankt
und dazu kommt das kogit patienten die
hier landen nicht nur schwer sondern
extrem schwer krank sind viele sterben
das belastet die mitarbeiter sehr wir
haben aber auch kollegen älteren
semesters die tatsächlich damit ganz
schön zu tun haben denn unser auftrag
ist ja tatsächlich zu heilen oder zu
entlassen oder zu verlegen und das sehen
wir tatsächlich nur bei einem kleinen
teil der patienten aktuell und von der
seite her gehen tatsächlich unsere
mitarbeiter häufig nach hause sehr
traurig niedergeschlagen und müssen sich
innerhalb ihres familiären
umfeldes aber eben halt auch innerhalb
dieses teams jeden tag neu motivieren
gerade jetzt über die feiertage war es
noch mal schlimmer weil da tatsächlich
die emotionale sache von den feiertag
noch dazu kam silvia köpfen und ihre
kollegen sehen die zerstörerische kraft
des virus täglich ihnen hilft jeder
lockdown noch eine kleine verwirrung von
vorhin klarzustellen die beschränkung
des bewegungsradius auf 15 kilometer
gelten ab einer inzidenz von 200 und
mehr ab einer inzidenz von 200 und mehr
nur dass sie das wissen hinter jeder
zahl stecken entsprechende schicksale
das gilt es im bewusstsein zu haben beim
blick auf die daten
das robert koch institut meldet knapp
12.000 neue infektionen binnen 24
stunden 944 menschen starben in
verbindung mit dem virus in den
bundesländern öffnen nach und nach die
impfzentren so wie hier in den
messehallen in hamburg stand heute
mittag haben deutschlandweit bislang
fast 300 17.000 menschen die erste
impfdosis bekommen wurden fehler gemacht
bei der beschaffung des corona
impfstoffs und wenn ja wer trägt die
verantwortung darüber streitet zurzeit
die koalition die spd zeigt auf
gesundheitsminister sparen von
chaotischen zuständen spricht
generalsekretär klingbeil und spd-chef
in essen sagt schwan müsse viele fragen
beantworten
mathis feldhoff berichtet es ist eine
gezielte attacke auf den
gesundheitsminister und wohl der versuch
ihm ganz persönlich den holprigen im
staat in die schuhe zu schieben
vier seiten 24 fragen und 49 unter
fragen ultimativ möchte die spd wissen
was falsch gelaufen ist etwa warum
können die zusätzlichen dosen in den usa
schneller geliefert werden als in der eu
oder hat die bundesregierung über die eu
hinaus bilateral über zukäufe von
impfstoff dosen verhandelt da gibt es
jetzt hinweise darauf dass dinge schief
gelaufen sind das nicht genug bestellt
wurde
und da gehört es dazu die dinge zu
thematisieren dass man jetzt auch
nachfragt die fragen sind intern
gestellt worden
und jetzt brauchen bezüglich aufklärung
als der gesundheitsminister gestern ins
corona kabinett kam wusste er schon von
der frageliste die der vizekanzler kurz
zuvor über sand hatte spanien gegend
heute mit sport das funktioniert in so
einer phase nicht gut gleichzeitig
regierung und opposition sein zu wollen
irgendwie hat es auch seit 20 jahren für
die spd nicht gut funktioniert ich
glaube nicht dass das jetzt im wahljahr
besser läuft dass die spd einen
koalitionsinternen zwist öffentlich
macht löst aber nicht nur beim
koalitionspartner verärgerung und
verwunderung aus ich finde es
verantwortungslos wenn ihnen den
intensivstationen dieses landes das
personal und menschen leben kämpft aber
am kabinettstisch eine gute presse
gekämpft wird wohl um zu schlichten aber
vor allem um die in kooperation zu
beschleunigen hat die kanzlerin für
morgen eine arbeitsgruppe einberufen mit
dabei auch scholz und sparen auch in
großbritannien werden die korona
maßnahmen wieder verschärft weil die
zahlen dort explodieren die nie
bleiben sie zu hause retten sie leben
appellierte prämie johnson an seine
englischen landsleute die neue corona
mutation verbreite sich im land
alarmierend in großbritannien gibt es
seit tagen immer wieder höchststände bei
den neuinfektionen
gestern waren es fast 59.000 andreas
stamm berichtet wieder verwaiste schul
korridore leergefegte straßen raus nur
zum einkaufen für arztbesuche auf die
arbeit los wenn es nicht anders geht
wieder heißt es zu hause bleiben
menschen retten mindestens sechs wochen
wird das öffentliche leben
heruntergefahren um den kollaps des
gesundheitssystems zu verhindern
wir haben keine wahl mehr als zwei
prozent der menschen sind infiziert das
sind allein in england mehr als eine
million und die zahl der koma patientin
im krankenhaus liegt 40 prozent über dem
höhepunkt der ersten welle im april
grund sei die ansteckende virus
mutationen die zuerst in südengland
auftauchte aber wohl auch die zu späte
reaktion der regierung darauf deren
große hoffnung mehr als eine million
menschen sind schon geimpft mit seit
gestern zwei impfstoffen in einem
ungetesteten verfahren die zweite dosis
wird jeweils nicht nach 3 sondern erst
zwölf wochen verabreicht in einer
solchen krise in der 500 menschen am tag
sterben bald 1000 und wie auf 100.000
infektionen am tag zu steuern
da muss man so viele kämpfen wie es nur
geht um so viele menschen wie möglich
mit dem schutz von erstmal einer dosis
zu retten
13 millionen die am meisten gefährdeten
und das medizinische personal will die
regierung schnellstmöglich impfen lassen
damit man ab mitte februar den lockdown
verlassen könne
was kritiker für träumerei halten bei
den zugelassenen vakzinen stockt es bei
der herstellung es fehle zudem an
personal und impfzentren es ist wieder
lockdown wieder werden die grundregeln
der pandemie deutlich gemacht mit hilfe
der impfstoffe hofft zumindest die
regierung vielleicht zum letzten mal in
die usa
dort geht es zwar nur um zwei sitze im
senat doch die entscheiden maßgeblich
über die macht des künftigen präsidenten
in der republikaner hochburg georgia hat
die stichwahl begonnen für diese zwei
sitze im sinne ab sollten sich die
beiden demokraten durchsetzen könnte joe
biden sehr viel einfacher regieren denn
dann hätte seine partei zusammen mit der
stimme von vizepräsident in harrislee
mehrheit im senat und damit in beiden
kammern des kongresses in ist raus für
präsident trump und seine fans scheint
das neue jahr zu beginnen wie das letzte
aufgehört hat mit einer kundgebung und
lügen von wahlbetrug
nach wie vor ist er überzeugt er habe
die wahl in georgia und im land gewonnen
hallo georgia und übrigens niemals haben
wir ja verloren die wahl manipuliert
aber wir kämpfen noch ihr werdet sehen
was passiert eigentlich ist er nach
georgia gekommen um für sie zu kämpfen
die beiden republikaner die erneut in
den senat wollen in einer stichwahl
treten sie heute gegen zwei demokraten
an hier links im bild gewinnen sie
hätten die demokraten damit auch die
mehrheit im mächtigen senat in
washington joe biden könnte bequem
durchregieren
ihr habt es in der hand zum ersten mal
in meiner laufbahn kann ein bundesstaat
den weg der gesamten nation bestimmen
nicht nur für vier jahre sondern für
eine ganze generation
die wahllokale in georgia geöffnet seit
dem morgen offen wie sehr trumps
rhetorik von wahlbetrug republikanische
wähler vom urnengang abhält die die
kommen wollen wählen jetzt erst recht
wenn ich nicht denjenigen wähle den ich
im amt haben will dann lasse ich doch
die andere seite einfach gewinnen wenn
ich nicht kämpfen
dann gebe ich von vornherein auf das bin
ich nicht der wahlausgang der stichwahl
könnte knapp werden und erst in tagen
vorliegen trump aber das scheint klar
will weiterhin nicht als verlierer vom
platz gehen jetzt der sport norbert
abschluss der vierschanzentournee in
oberstdorf wollte ich jetzt schon fast
sagen nämlich in bischofshofen
so kann man sich irren und da haben die
deutschen skispringer gern noch chancen
auf einen podestplatz markus
eisenbichler fünfter in der
gesamtwertung karl geiger vierter der
zeigte allerdings heute in der
qualifikation eine eher schwache
leistung
es war nicht der sprung der euphorie
entfacht für den finaltag nur 123
einheit meter für karl geiger
er landet abgeschlagen auf rang 25
morgen muss er dadurch im ersten duell
antreten und den wettkampf eröffnet
zuversichtlich stimmt die leistung von
markus eisenbichler der skisprung
weltmeister kommt auf eine weite von 134
metern und wird als achter bester
deutscher kam jetzt doch gewinnt die
qualifikation mit seinem sprung auf 138
meter und hohen haltungsnoten diakonie
führende aus polen unterstreicht damit
vor dem morgigen finale seine
favoritenrolle
die entscheidung in bischofshofen morgen
live um 16 uhr 45 im zdf handball em
quali schon ab 13 uhr 30
erster auftritt von bo svensson als
neuer coach beim abstiegsbedrohten
fußball bundesligisten aus mainz der ex
spieler und co-trainer der 05 erhält
einen dreijahresvertrag der auch für die
zweite liga gilt der däne wurde heute
der presse vorgestellt und fand dort
klar
worte es gibt eine leistungsgarantie und
es gibt einfach eine art und weise wie
man sich benimmt wie man agiert wie man
fußball spielt und es wird knallhart und
konsequent dann auch durchgezogen
liverpool patzt auswärts im titelkampf
trainer klopp völlig frustriert
southampton scoach hasenhüttl dagegen
vergisst freudentränen nach dem 1 0-sieg
sales coach ralph hasenhüttl r weint vor
glück zum ersten mal in seinem leben
gewinnt er ein spiel gegen jürgen klopp
könnte nicht stolzer sein auf mein team
ja es war ein ganz besonderer moment war
ich immer schön
schon in minute zwei gelingt ex
liverpooler dennings dieser sehenswerten
lupfer
eins zu null und so bleibt es liverpool
zum dritten mal nacheinander ohne sieg
hasenhüttl bewegt viel in southhampton
hat jetzt nur noch vier punkte rückstand
auf tabellenführer liverpool das was
bitte vorsicht wenn sie nach draußen
gehen von osten ziehen schnee und regen
auf es wird glatt auf den straßen heute
nacht und morgen mehr dazu gleich von
katar um 22 uhr bringt sie in marietta
slomka im heute journal auf den neues
stand morgen übernimmt hier petra
gerster ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen
abend erinnere noch mal an das zdf
spezial jetzt gleich im anschluss und
sagt tschüss ans gute ihn
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren schnee und
glätte können wir im januar ja durchaus
erwarten ungewöhnlich an dieser
wetterlage ist einzig dass beides von
osten kommt heute flockt es vor allen
dingen hier in den mittelgebirgen in
norddeutschland war es mehr regen dabei
ist die grenze zwischen regen
gefrierendem regen schneeregen und
schnee auch in der nacht fließend es
schneit zunächst hier in sachsen dann
auch in thüringen bis zum frühen morgen
erreichen die schneefälle auch das
südliche niedersachsen und auch am
alpenrand flockt es etwas sie sollten
sich allerdings bei tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen plus zwei und minus fünf grad
überall auf gefährlich glatte straßen
und gehwege einstellen an der ostsee
pfeift ein bürger nord nordosten die
schnee und schneeregen wollten ziehen
morgen über norddeutschland weiter
überdecken ganz nordrhein westfalen und
niedersachsen und auch am alpenrand
zwischen dem allgäu und im bayerischen
wald lockt es kann einige zentimeter
neuschnee zusammenkommen und zum teil
eben auch liegen bleiben
auch morgen sollten sie auf
straßenglätte gefasst sein bei
höchsttemperaturen zwischen minus ein
und plus vier grad
am donnerstag fällt noch schnee und
schneeregen zwischen der ostseeküste und
dem niederrhein am freitag klappt es vor
allen dingen noch im osten der samstag
wird er trocken
schönen abend noch